[Music]
caress of the gaze is an art project by
architect and designer Benassi for rocky
it combines 3d printing shape memory
alloy and computer vision technologies
to explore a vision of the future where
our clothing behaves like a second skin
bristling swelling and transforming in
response to an observers gaze I'm
basically exploring the relationship of
human body to the space in various
scales one of them is near environmental
scales which is fashion or basically
garments are closing and then on the
other hand I'm interested explore how
the environment can inform our bodily
presence into space the best which isn't
for sale was inspired by involuntary
biological responses like pupil dilation
and yawning and the chills an eye
tracking camera positioned above the
sternum controls the garment which like
goosebumps behaves independently of the
body it covers it can say back off
without uttering a word a big obstacle
to creating lifelike movement was
designing something that could Bend and
flex repeatedly when you 3d print a
rigid substrate beside a flexible one a
break will eventually form where they
meet FRA he overcame this hurdle by
printing her garment across a gradient
of thicknesses the result looks
surprisingly organic and behaves like an
extension of the wearer's body if
Rocky's piece is slated to appear next
step weary at a show in Paris all of
these things at the very end I think
it's about connecting us and our body to
the space around
[Music]